parmi les dispositifs préconisé par le
président de la république et par
beaucoup d'autres aussi à l'ouverture
des grandes écoles aux élèves des
quartiers défavorisés
avec des voies d'accès parallèle c'est
une pratique qui se développe en france
on a beaucoup parlé de sciences po 57
grandes écoles au total ont suivi
l'exemple l'essec une des écoles de
commerce les plus prestigieuses a été
l'une des premières reportage diego
garcia virginie travers égalité des
chances cette fois elie croit vraiment
tiana passent le bac en ce moment dans
un lycée réputé difficile depuis la
seconde elle suit aussi un programme
pour entrer dans une grande école
l'essec et une école supérieure de
commerce lui a beaucoup appris aussi
plus d'aisance à l'oral quand il faut
s'exprimer devant un public et plus de
confiance en moi aussi argument des
grandes écoles elles ont tout intérêt à
recruter les meilleurs élèves des
milieux défavorisés
plutôt que les moyens des milieux
favorisés pendant trois ans
chaque lycéen peut compter sur un tuteur
qui va l'aider et l'épauler tous les
sujets sont abordés
on essaie d'éviter un peu leur esprit
critique d'éveiller leur curiosité donc
tout ça c'est ont choisi des sujets
d'actualité
à dire un sujet une semaine et on l'a
travaillé dessus comme ici à sciences po
paris 57 grandes écoles recrutent chaque
année une dizaine de lycéens la
promotion de l'égalité des chances
priorités du gouvernement fait son
chemin dans les grandes écoles de
l'exigence bienveillante c'est à dire qu
on les entraîne à travailler plus
parce que qui dit grande école du
travail supplémentaire et puis ça leur
donne une ouverture et un enrichissement
qui ne peuvent pas trouver au lycée en
2003 2004 sur trente six mille six cents
nouveaux étudiants inscrits en première
année de classe préparatoire aux grandes
écoles
seulement 4% et est titulaire d'un bac
technique contre 95% qui avait un bac
général